by the time your child is 12 years old
you've already spent 75 percent of the
time in your life that you will spend
with them by the time they are 18 you've
spent 90 percent of the time you're
likely to spend with them across the
course of your life you only have about
10 percent left through the course of
their entire adulthood that you are
going to touch base with them or see
them and that is a very modern concept
because that is not how humans are meant
to function about a hundred years ago
most people didn't move more than 15
miles from the place of their birth they
wouldn't even travel or they would get
lost and never be able to find their way
home now I'm just gonna pack up on a
move to Dubai and then maybe I'll move
to Australia I don't know what Dad's
doing oh he's dead that's really sad I
will cry later but first I have to fly
to France this is becoming so much more
common that is Modern Life yeah that's
terrifying